can anyone talk about what the volume
has been or had been here at this site
uh and what it has become since it's
since it's opened up
yes um
chris with i'm the site manager for
white cross
um originally we're having uh 40 to 60
people a day
today we should hit up to 300
uh over the past few days it's increased
twofold pretty much every day have you
heard why from some of these
from people we've gotten some publicity
from our local leaders uh like the mayor
and also
opening up the registration or or taking
away the registration rather so that
people can know that they can just drive
up and get their vaccine that's been
helpful
um and also the age opening of the age
so anybody succeeding over can get a
vaccine
remember can you comment on the signing
of the voting rights bill yesterday
all of the arrests that worked out for
me
well it wasn't a voting rights bill it
was an election security bill that
actually
increases early voting opportunities on
the weekend here in georgia also
requires a photo id for absentee by mail
just like when you vote
in person and it continues to i think
will allow georgia to have secured
accessible
fair elections in georgia as far as
representative cannon
you know you'd have to question or ask
the
georgia department of public safety
about you know what happened there
it's unfortunate that a sitting state
representative would
actually stomp and kick a georgia state
patrol officer
that'll be it guys thank for that that's
american astrology so tell us your name
please my name is michelangelo james
thank you um what have you been hearing
from folks in and around white cross
originally about why there was a
hesitancy to
get the vaccine past training
experience that they've had in times
past with different types of
vaccinations
and especially in many cases when people
are hesitant it's because of lack of
education as well and many of them have
been educated
recently so that's been helpful thank
you thank you everybody